في الاثناء احذر زعيم وحزب فرنسا الابيه
جولي كمال عاشور الرئيسه مكروم من ان
الغضب يتصاعد عليه ان يسمع للجماهير وشد
داخل مشاركته في المظاهرات اليوم على ان
رفع سن التقاعد ليس له شرعيه برلمانيه وان
المظاهرات ستتواصل حتى تتراجع الحكومه عن
قرارها
انها معركه الحريه وهي معركه لا تناقش
وانما تمارس وممارستنا لها تفيد باننا لا
نرغب في تقاعد بعمر 64 عاما لا شرعيه لذلك
نحن ننتقل نحو نمط استبداادي وعنيف
والجميع يلاحظون ذلك ماذا يجب ان نفعل
علينا ان نواصل انه الامر الوحيد الذي في
متناول ايدينا ماذا يمكننا فعله غير ذلك
انها اراده الشعب الفرنسي في مواجهه اراده
الحكومه التي اتخذت قرارها اكرر يجب ان
نواصل حتى التراجع عن ذلك
[موسيقى]